despite what the critics said about
marches record-breaking Superman be
Batman it seems a whole lot of people
love the bat flick I'm Simon and this is
your dark knight news on things this
week at cinemacon Warner Brothers CEO
Kevin tsujihara confirmed that the
studio have been working on a new
standalone Batman adventure with Ben
Affleck speaking about the film
company's upcoming lineup the executive
finally made it official we're working
with Ben Affleck on a standalone Batman
movie as reported by comic book com the
confirmation follows comments from a
talent agency executive who said in
March that Affleck is signed up to play
the Caped Crusader in two upcoming
Justice League movies and as ideas for
another film beyond that he's contracted
to do at least Justice League one and
two so at least three times wearing the
Cape there's a script that he's written
that is a really cool idea so that's out
there as an option in March Affleck said
in an interview with Entertainment
Weekly that Warner Brothers plan to make
another Batman movie the stopped short
of revealing his involved there's
definitely willingness and a will and a
desire to make a Batman movie on the
part of Warner Brothers he said it's in
development and right now I'm really
focused on finishing live by night
that's where my focus is and I tend to
be a one movie at a time guy when I'm
finished with this movie I'll then focus
on my next movie and figure out what
that would be Catholic has been rumored
to be the studio's choice of director
for a standalone Batman film for some
time in 2015 it was reported that is
deal with the studio to play the
character in Batman V Superman also
included him writing and directing the
future movie for Warner Brothers do you
long for more bat flick or do you think
there needs to be more Dark Knight
decision making let me know in the
comments below or find me on Twitter I'm
at the general thanks for watching and
for all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot